hi my name is pravan jin
and i'm going to talk about
pre-constrained encryption this is in
joint work with abhishek jain
zhang jong jin and julia muller-walter
end-to-end encryption is now more
important than ever
most of our day-to-day activities
happens over the internet
and indeed like many organizations have
taken into an uh encryption seriously
and have incorporated this on their
platforms
so the simplest form
uh end-to-end encryption works like this
you know let's say there are a couple of
users
both of them have a shared key
that they use to encrypt the messages
that they send to each other
and the messages are usually sent
through some platform owned by some
organization
so now the question is who generates the
key k right so suppose it's a user is
using the key
to
encrypt these messages who generates
this key
so there are two possibilities we can
consider
one is that the organization
which is handling
the
message transmission mechanism
itself generates a key or maybe the user
generates the key
let's consider these two cases
separately
the first case is when the when the some
organization generates the key
in this case there are a couple of
issues uh that could occur so one is
data breach
so what could happen is that suppose
let's say an organization stores a
database of keys of all the users
it could happen that you know set of
hackers hack into the system
and then they steal all the keys
in this database right
so this compromises uh the privacy of
all the users that are using this
particular part platform
another issue that could occur is mass
surveillance
so it could happen that you know law
enforcement agencies or government
could
maybe subpoena an organization to reveal
the
set of keys that they have stored in the
database
and
once the
organization is sort of forced to reveal
the set of keys it has stored
there is no control over how the law
enforcement agencies can use the set of
user keys
they could
perhaps use it to conduct mass
surveillance and
we no longer will have any control over
what they do
so it seems like there are two major
problems associated
i mean the two major problems that occur
if we allow the organization to generate
the key
keys
so let's go to the other scenario
where the user is the one who generates
the key
so here too there are a couple of major
issues
the first major issue is that
there won't be any access to
the law enforcement right so what does
this mean so suppose let's say
there's a criminal that
the law enforcement agencies have been
able to identify
then they recover
a device of this criminal
and they realize that this device
contains some encrypted contents
so
um now if the criminal is the one who
generated the key and has maybe
destroyed it somehow
then the law enforcement agencies will
have no way to recover the underlying
data
so
potentially this data could contain some
sensitive material that the law
enforcement agencies could have used to
stop further crime
and now they will
no longer have access to it and this is
an issue
so the other issue is that
this restricts computing on encrypted
data
so what does this mean so suppose let's
say
the user encrypts his data denoted here
by m
using the key he generated he or she
don't generate it and
suppose let's say this ciphertext is
stored
in some cloud service
so now um we often want the cloud
service to perform some useful
computations on this encrypted data
the cloud service can perform some sort
of homomorphic computation on this
encrypted data but the problem is the
result is still encrypted right and
the organization cannot decrypt this
because they don't have the decryption
key
of course you can ask the user to
decrypt it or like you can maybe ask the
user to generate some keys for you
but uh this process involves more
overhead and it's uh adds more
and it's more cumbersome
um
so
this has sort of led to the encryption
debate uh on one hand you have users and
privacy advocates
and on the other end you have the
government and the law enforcement
agencies
so the users and privacy advocates are
fighting to keep and encryption they are
saying that
uh end-to-end encryption is a necessity
on the other hand uh
the government and law enforcement
agencies have actively called for
abolishing end-to-end encryption
so
the natural question we ask
you know in this in this work is is
there a middle ground
can we come up with a solution
that
can satisfy both
these different
entities
entities on the different sides of the
aisle
and
we introduce a notion towards addressing
this very very complex issue uh we
introduce a notion
called uh pre-constrained encryption
so what is pre-constraint encryption
um so in this notion we say that you
know we
uh go back to the first setting where
the organization is the one who
generates the key the decryption key
we're going to call this organization an
authority from now on it generates a
decryption key k star
however this
key k star does
not have unlimited decryption power
uh this key k star
can only recover restricted amount of
information about the underlying message
so what does it mean for k-star to have
limited decryption power let's
look into that
using an example
so
you can have
two ciphertexts the first ciphertext has
some problematic
message it has some something that
could
that might be illegal right it might
correspond to some illegal activity uh
for example it can say something like
let's rob a bank
so in this case using k-star you should
be able to recover the message
on the other hand you can have a message
that is very not innocuous i mean it's
it's very harmless
uh for example you know we could be
saying like i'm attending itcs
so in this case uh you should using this
key you should not be able to decrypt
the underlying message
so this is kind of the decryption power
we want so we want to be able to decrypt
only those messages
that might be problematic all the other
messages that are innocuous should
um should not be able to decrypt using
this key case down
right so and one thing i want to make
clear is that
we are not trusting the authority here
even if the authority is malicious
even if the authority generates k-star
arbitrarily meaning that
it might not even follow the
description of setup algorithm it can it
can generate k star however it wants
even then we want k star to have limited
decryption power
so this is an important uh property that
we need from our notion
um so in particular you know even if the
key k star is is generated
maliciously
um
if if i have a message saying like i'm
attaining itcs should still not be able
to decrypt
so more formally how do we
how do we define this notion of limited
decryption power
so we consider a function space so we
consider a function class that is
associated with our notion of
pre-constrained encryption
and we partition this
function class into two categories
one category corresponds to authorized
set
the other category corresponds to the
unauthorized set
and
we require that
whatever information
the
you know you can recover from k star
corresponds to this authorized set so
you could have any function in this
authorized set the you know using k star
you can only recover the output of the
function
in this set on the message
okay
so suppose let's say there's a user here
you know there's a key k star associated
with it he encrypts the message m using
the public key ppk
uh generated by the organization
and now
um using k star you can recover f of m
if and only if f is authorized f belongs
to this authorized set
and how do you determine f is authorized
i mean this depends on k star so k star
essentially determines what are the
class of functions that are authorized
and what are the class of functions that
are not authorized
okay
so
you might ask this question so it seems
like using k star i can only recover f
of m uh in the case when f is authorized
but
what if i want to record the entire
message right i mean
in many settings
we do want to make sure that someone can
decrypt the ciphertext completely and
how can we ensure using this
so we can fix this
problem by introducing another mode so
in addition to this
notion that we are using
which is pre-constrained encryption
i can use another normal end to end
encryption
um
you know corresponding to this red key k
so now the user encrypts with respect to
both key k star and k
and sends this cipher text over
and uh a user that has this key k the
red key can decrypt the message all the
time
so it's not associated with any
functions and as long as it has k this
is like the master key it can recover
the message all the time
so more formally you know you have these
two modes in one mode
you can think of the authority being
able to recover f m only if f is
authorized using the blue key k star
whereas an end user another user will be
able to recover key k
or recover the message m if it has the
red key key
all the time
okay
okay so this is like the in the overview
of our notion so we're going to um
uh we already said that the authority
could be could
even if the authority is malicious
k-star should have limited decryption
power so just give you like an overview
of uh whatever notion entails to
um so we're going to like
go into the details
more formally
so before that i want to mention one
more thing which is that
depending on how
k star is defined you can have two
extreme cases
in one extreme case you can have the set
of all functions to be authorized in
this case
the organization of the authority can
decrypt everything right it can recover
f of m for every m which means that you
can
recover the entire message m
on the other hand you can define case
statuses that all the functions are
unauthorized in which case the
organization
or the or the authority can decrypt
nothing so these are the two extreme
cases
okay
so just to give you some examples of
authorized classes of functions
you know you can have a function that
says you output one
if and only if the input contains some
objectional material for example
um you know we
looked at the message that said let's
rob a bank this contains some
objectional material in this case um you
know should
you know if
you have a function that outputs one
uh you can also have a function that
outputs one if and only if the input is
a spam email right so you're only
you're only authorizing functions
uh
that classify the input as spam
any other function that's trying to
learn some additional information about
the message is classified as
unauthorized
so depending on the kind of applications
you're looking at you can define the
authorized class of functions
so the first bullet corresponds to
corresponds more to
what sort of information law enforcement
agencies might need
uh
from from the encrypted data and the
second
bullet point might correspond to
what organizations might want to
compute on the encrypted data
okay so let me get into the formal
details um
so
the the notion of pre-constraint
encryption consists of many algorithms
the first algorithm is a setup algorithm
that takes as input circuit c
um and outputs
two keys one is skn another one is pk
sk is the secret key and pk is the
public key
what is c
c corresponds to a constraint circuit
so remember i mentioned that
the key sort of classifies the
sort of partitions the class of
functions into two categories one was
the authorized
authorized and the unauthorized set
um and the classification is done via
this constraint circuit c right so if
c on input of function outputs 1 then
it's authorized
if c on input a function output 0 then
it's unauthorized
so c essentially partitions the class of
functions
so and then you have the
encryption and the decryption algorithms
as in any encryption scheme so the
encryption algorithm is the same so i am
not going to go over it so the
decryption algorithm in addition to the
decryption key also takes as input f and
c t
and
the decryption algorithm outputs f of x
if and only if f is an authorized
function in other words c of f is 1.
so this is how decryption is defined
so
um
going back to the earlier example so the
organization produces pk and k star
using the setup algorithm
um
that k star is sk
and then the user encrypts the message m
using the public key
and then you can decrypt
using k star and f to get f m
only if f is authorized
you can consider
another scenario where it's not the
authority that is uh
doing the decryption and recovering of
him but instead it's some law
enforcement agency
so in this case how will the agency
recover f of m right so one way could be
that the authority
sort of shares this kk star with fbi
or like some other law enforcement
agency and then they can recover f f m
for any authorized function f
but maybe the authority is not
comfortable with sharing this decryption
key
uh in this case how will the
law enforcement agency recover ffm
so what could perhaps be useful is some
sort of a key delegation feature
where
from this k star you can recover
a restricted key skf
and then the law enforcement agency can
use this restricted kskf to recover ffm
so if uh preconstrained encryption had
this
additional feature then that would be
useful
so we're going to study this additional
feature
this is accompanied by an algorithm
called keygen algorithm that takes as
input the secret key sk and function f
and outputs skf
this is a
fun it's a sort of a functional key
associated with f
and the decryption algorithm uh now
takes as input as kf and ct and outputs
f of x
um as long as f is an authorized
function in other words uh c of f is one
right and just to recall uh c is the
circuit that's uh input to the setup
algorithm so this is a constraint
circuit
okay so what are the properties we
require um there are three properties
that we require one is correctness which
says that you know should be able to
recover f of m
as long as f is authorized so this this
should be allowed
the other property is that
even if the authority is malicious
we should not be able to recover f m for
any unauthorized death
so defining the security notion is
somewhat
non-trivial and challenging
so i won't have
time to go into the details here i
encourage you to look at the discussion
in our paper
and finally we have the constraint
heading property
where we required that the public key pk
hires a circuit c
okay so there are a few like special
cases of pre-constrained encryption that
are useful for us
so let's look at these special cases
the first special case is called
attribute based
pre-constraint encryption
and
the the set of functionalities
associated with this notion is very
similar to the type of functionalities
which we have studied in attribute based
encryption
hence the hence the name attribute-based
pc
so this function
uh every function uh in this family
takes its input uh x and m there are
it's it has the input as two parts
and it outputs m if and only if some
function g where
this function f is parameterized by g
where this function g outputs 0 on x
and
you can also consider the identity based
pre-constrained encryption
so this is again defined uh analogous to
identity based encryption
so here the
function
in this function class
uh
is uh every function of this function
class is parameterized by some identity
id star
uh it takes this input id and m
uh and outputs them if and only if id
equals id star
okay
um so let's state our results
so
there are we we have many results in the
paper so i'm only going to give a
snippet of what are the most important
results in the talk
so the first result um is that we show
that pc is as powerful as i o we show
implication from pc to io and also
the other way around
we also use some additional assumptions
in the in these transformations
which i'm not going to
uh highlight uh in this talk
i encourage you to look at the paper
uh for the uh precise assumptions used
to go from one one to to the other
and then we show that you can construct
the special cases of uh preconceived
encryption which are the
identity based pre-constructed
encryption and attribute based on
pre-constraint encryption from uh the
learning with the ros assumption
so for identity based pc we get it for
all kinds of
identity based functionalities
from learning with errors whereas for
attribute based pc we only get four
point constraints
right so so in the identity based pc
there's no restriction on what the
constraint circuit can be what the
circuit c can be in attribute based pc
the circuit c has to be a point
constraint
so so what is what is a point constraint
a point constraint is associated with
a point some point x star it's a binary
string
and it outputs one on all the functions
that
output 1 on x star right so this
constraint c takes us input a function f
and outputs 1
if and only if f
outputs one on x star
okay so um
this notion of pc
seems very similar to the notion of
function encryption that is fundamental
to cryptography
so what are the main differences i mean
there are two main differences
the first difference is that
if you ignore the key delegation feature
of pre-constrained encryption it's
still a non-trivial
uh
non-trivial primitive to achieve whereas
if you
take functional encryption and then
strip off the key delegation feature
then it coincides with the the notion of
standard encryption right so this is
something that we are very very familiar
with
the other
uh difference is that
you know collusion resistance is not
guaranteed so what do i mean by this
so suppose let's say you know i give you
uh keys corresponding to
functions f1 through fq
so
in pc
there is
no guarantee that
using the outputs of these or rather
using the keys corresponding to f1
through fq you cannot recover
the output of the function
f q plus 1 on the input
as long as this function f q plus one is
authorized you could obtain the output
of f q plus one on the input and and the
function and then the
and the encryption scheme does not
disallow this uh scenario
whereas in function encryption if you
get a bunch of keys
then the only information you
essentially can learn
are the outputs of the functions
associated with these keys and nothing
more
right so collision resistance is a very
very important part of function
encryption whereas bc does not guarantee
that
so in the in the paper we have a little
more in-depth discussion on the
differences between these two notions we
encourage you to look at it
um so in terms of
related work i mean
questioning the trust
of
questioning whether to trust the
authority who generates
the setup is not new to our work and has
been studied extensively in the crypto
literature
um
you know it starts with the started with
the work of bernie franklin who raised
the question of
uh constructing encryption systems with
multiple authorities you know
like there are multiple authorities each
of them produce
some keys and then
you know the the
security of the overall system is
guaranteed as long as we trust
a subset of these authorities
so this has been studied in the context
of identity-based encryption attributes
based encryption and so on
and then we also have the notion of
accountable authority
um
the here you know there's authority who
we
you know who we know has maliciously
deviated from the protocol
uh we have like evidence that this
authority has cheated we can hold it
accountable right
due to an external judge right so that's
this this notion has also been studied
uh in the context of advanced encryption
systems
we also have like registration based
encryption
um which is more closely related to
identity based encryption where
um there is no like single set up uh
trusted authority who produces
uh the public key instead
all the users like produce public keys
on their own and there is sort of like
an aggregation feature which aggregates
all these different public key into a
short public key
so in some sense it
tells us how to get rid of the trusted
authority altogether
okay so we're going to um go into the
technical details of our of our work and
we're only going to focus on attribute
based pre-constraint encryption for
point constraints right and we're going
to show how to construct this from the
learning with rest assumption
so the main insight in our
construction is the following
we
observe that
uh there are
uh
selected there are proofs of
advanced encryption systems
uh specifically like selective security
proofs of advanced encryption systems in
the cryptographic in the cryptography
literature
which have a very
special structure that we can exploit
to construct preconstrained encryption
right so in some sense we are you know
we observe that you can turn
some
proofs with very special
structure into into constructions right
and that's uh that's our insight
um
and just to go into this in a bit more
detail uh
you know the
the typical way to define selective
security is that you have a challenge or
an adversary that adversary needs to
sort of declare some challenge message
at the very beginning of the experiment
for example you can think of
standard encryption or even like
identity-based encryption
attribute-based encryption and so on so
the the adversary is supposed to declare
the message in the very beginning
uh even before the challenger starts
giving out the public parameters
okay um so
again like if you are looking at more
advanced encryption systems like you
will also have these like key query
phase which the adversary can do
um
where the adversary queries are function
and the challenger returns back some
functional key and so on right and this
key query phase can happen over many
many iterations
so typically
you know
the way you prove selective security is
you know as by a sequence of hybrids
and
there is like a very
important hybrid
which shows up in many selected security
proofs so what is this hybrid in this
hybrid you have a challenger
who produces a fake
secret key and a fake public key
such that this fake secret key
is does is it says that it cannot even
issue keys for
inadmissible functions
so
um what functions are in
inadmissible it depends on the specific
notion we are considering
um for example the class of inaudible
functions might be different for
identity based encryption attribute
based encryption and so on
so
so in the intermediate hybrids like you
you know there's a point where the
challenger produces a fake secret key in
a public key where the secret key does
not even if you have the secret you
cannot issue keys for these admissible
functions
and
this sort of hybrid is very useful for
our
uh
our notion of preconceived encryption
why
because
i can use this procedure to create the
setup algorithm of pc
right so setup algorithm takes us input
x star
so recall x star is like the challenge
attribute declared by the adversary
um so in our setting extra corresponds
to the point constraint
the setup outputs
sk fake and pk fake as as
done by the challenger
so the key generation algorithm can
issue keys for any function that is
admissible right
so in our case we can define
admissibility in terms of um
you know
whether it's authorized or not right so
the class of admissible functions
corresponds to the class of authorized
functions for us
so keygen can issue skf if and only if f
is admissible right now if it's not
admissible skfa can simply not issue the
key
okay so with this sort of high level
idea in mind we will see how to
construct uh pre-constrained encryption
for point constraints and the
inspiration for our construction will
come from the selectively secure
a b construction by uh
bone agent tree corbinal halevi
nikolenko
okay
so
what is the setup algorithm of our
pre-constructed encryption notion the
setup algorithm takes us input x star
and outputs a bunch of matrices okay so
um
each i mean you you have the matrix a
where matrix a is of dimension n cross m
uh m is like roughly n log q where q is
the
field size
so every entry in this matrix comes from
zq
and the number of columns is roughly n
log q
so the matrix a and then you have a
bunch of matrices that encode x star
the first matrix encodes the first bit
of fixed r the second matrix encodes the
second bit of x star and so on
right so the encoding is defined as a r
i minus x i star g where r i is a matrix
0 1 um entry matrix
sampled uniformly random
p is an n cross matrix that is sampled
uniformly at random as well
and g is the gadget matrix
that is
used
in
many lattice-based constructions
so this is the public key
and the secret key is
r1 through rl and you also have x star
um so a anyone who is familiar with the
the proof of security of the
reconstruction by boeing at all
we'll realize that the public key
and secret kia stated here
is
what would be generated by the
challenger in the hybrid experiments
okay
and then we have the set encryption
algorithm which is essentially the same
as bone at all encryption
um so you have the encodings of
x i
uh and then you have the encodings of um
oh there's a typo here this has to be um
this has to be s not s s transpose
so you have encodings of x i and then
you have encoding of the message m
and then you have
give out the lwe sample
okay
so how do we generate the key uh the key
is going to be a short trap door
um
like short just means that the trapdoor
contains very small entries
such that if you consider the
concatenation of these two matrices a
and a r f plus g where r f is
some
function
associated with f and the matrices are
one through r l
um
you know plus g so if uh if you consider
the concatenation of these two matrices
multiply with t you're going to get zero
um we can produce this trapdoor using a
procedure called
as sample write procedure so you're
going to use
the fact that rf contains um small
entries and you know what rf is
now you're also going to use the fact
that you know the trap door for g to
produce t
so if you're familiar with the bone at
all paper
they actually use the sample left
procedure to produce the trap door they
use the fact that they know the trap
door for a
to to
produce t but in our case we're using
um like we don't know the trap to fray
physical is the fact that we know our rf
and the chapter for g to produce t
okay
um
so one thing that we didn't take into
consideration is the fact that a could
be generated arbitrarily right and uh
like for all you know the authority
could generate a with the trap door
um
generate a along with the trapdoor for a
in which case it can actually generate a
key for any function it wants
you know irrespective of whether it this
function outputs
0 or 1 on x star
so what we do is we first of all
consider the setting where it's
malicious meaning that
uh the adversary can the authority can
pick whatever randomness it wants for
setup but it's still running the setup
honestly
in this case by imposing some structure
on a
uh inspired by the work by bricker skin
dartling we can argue that the
like the the construction still
satisfies security
and in the second step uh we can go what
we do is we go from some malicious to
militia security this is a this is
completely a generic construction
uh we can start with any semi-malicious
abe and we can compile it to a malicious
lee secure a b construction
um where malicious here just means that
the setup could be maliciously generated
um
so in this case you can go from one to
the other
using uh secret sharing and and also
like non-interactive witness
indistinguishable proofs
so these are the tools used but uh i'm
not going to go over how this
transformation is done
right so this sort of concludes the the
discussion on how to construct
uh
attribute based pc for point constraints
so you can um
okay so so to conclude we introduce a
new notion called pre-constraint
encryption and we give constructions of
this notion from different assumptions i
think this is an exciting exciting
notion that has um
potentially
not only other theoretical applications
i mentioned that it implies i o so this
could be a new pathway to construct i o
but it also has uh implications um
to
potentially like
to aid law enforcement and
handle in recovering some information
about encrypted data while at the same
time not giving unlimited power to law
enforcement
so in that way this this is both theory
and potentially applied applications
uh applied applications um and uh there
is more work to be done
thanks